Coffee or caffeine in the morning is a
necessity
after all it stimulates your central
nervous system elevates your mood and
increases your alertness but for those
times that it's not available or for
those who don't drink it here are some
scientific tips to kick your body into
gear number one find the light melatonin
is a hormone secreted by the brain and
is critical in regulating your sleep
when it's dark your body produces more
melatonin making you sleepy and when
it's light the production of melatonin
drops so open those curtains go outside
and expose yourself to light in the
morning to decrease melatonin production
and physiologically wake your body up if
you have to wake up in darkness try an
illuminating alarm clock they slowly
fill your room with light to wake you up
naturally to end your shower with cold
water
studies show that exposing yourself to
cold water can activate components of
the brain responsible for regulating
wakefulness making you feel alert
researchers have also found that the
shock of cold shower water can increase
your metabolic rate further reducing
feelings of fatigue 3 hydrate yourself
up to 60% of your body is water while
sleeping you sweat breathe get up to
urinate or poop all of which dehydrate
you studies show that even mild
dehydration decreases alertness
increases fatigue and negatively affects
mental concentration so in the morning
at grab a glass of water to replenish
your fluids to fight off that tired
feeling and don't forget to drink water
throughout the day to stay alert for eat
a healthy breakfast researchers have
found that participants feel more alert
after consuming a meal first thing in
the morning if the meal was high in
simple sugars like a doughnut the
alertness wore off quickly whereas if
the meal was high in fiber and
carbohydrates like oats alertness lasted
longer throughout the morning another
study found that breakfast high in fat
tastes better but led to consuming more
food throughout the day as opposed to a
high fiber and carbohydrate breakfast
which satiated hunger and increased
cognitive function throughout the day 5
drink some orange juice citrus fruits
like oranges are rich in molecules
called flavonoids flavonoids have been
linked to slowing cognitive decline due
to aging and too
creasing the onset of neurodegenerative
diseases like Alzheimer's one study
found that participants who consumed
flavonoid rich orange juice had
increased alertness and cognitive
function compared to their counterparts
who were fed a placebo number six be
physically active in the morning studies
have found that physically active
students perform better on tests and
those who are less active physical
activity enhances cognition due to the
increased blood flow throughout the body
providing your brain with more oxygen
and increasing mental performance and
the hippocampus which is part of the
brain critical for learning and memory
is highly active during exercise in
seven listen to music music has the
ability to create a state of arousal
causing pupils to dilate and blood
pressure to increase it can also
increase activation in regions of the
brain associated with movement and
demotion while potentially releasing the
feel-good chemical dopamine throughout
your body so build that wake up the
playlist and subscribe for more weekly
science videos